welcome to program your mo today we're
going to be looking at a Toyota remote
programming procedure that covers many
different toyota vehicles if you're
unsure what procedure your vehicle takes
you can visit our web-site program your
remote comm so let's get started first
thing we want to do is make sure the key
is out of the ignition and the driver's
door is open you want all the other
doors to be closed and unlocked now
we're gonna take the key and without
turning put it all the way in the
ignition and all the way out now using
the switch on the driver's door we're
gonna do a cycle of pressing the lock
and then unlock five times one two three
four and five and we're gonna close and
open the driver's door and do the five
cycles again one two three four five now
we're gonna take our key put it in the
ignition
and go from on to off and remove the key
the door locks cycled indicating the
vehicle is now in programming mode so
we'll grab our remote and press the lock
and unlock button at the same time now
press just the lock button for about two
seconds to door lock cycled indicating
this remote has now successfully been
programmed if you have no other remotes
you can skip this next step if you do
have another remote to program you'll
repeat the previous step
pressing bolt to lock and unlock button
once and then just the lock button for
about two seconds one two door lock
cycled indicating this remote has now
been programmed if you have any other
remotes to add you'll continue that
previous step for each remote once
you're done adding remotes you can close
the door that's gonna exit programming
mode now let's test the remotes
those are working remotes thanks for
watching everyone